weil die sind wirklich die ganze zeit da
wo [ __ ] it nein junge niederbipp be an
max mit dem volk tipps gehen und mein
was war das für eine anzeige
wir spielen heute in time und der sg ist
auch mit dabei so wahrscheinlich einfach
wenig weil er nicht sc ist sondern
wandte 2000 abgesprochen für meine
zuschauer die das vielleicht noch nicht
kennen
ich habe gerade eben auch meine
allererste rum gespielt und bin gleich
relativ weit gekommen von so relativ
kühl sonst würde ich jetzt nicht
aufnehmen
spielmann das auf kino.de und es geht
darum mannschaft mit zehn minuten zeit
und man kann für zeit items kaufen bei
virgin die glaube ich random auf der
karte sparen und muss halt schauen so
ein bisschen strategischer als das
normale survival games bisschen mehr
das cable einschätzungssache und grad
wird wieder so zeit verteilt dieses
nervige warten was ihr gehört meine
sound ein bisschen leiser machen weil es
echt nervt der nacht arbeiten dann mache
ich das schon als kleiner tipp doch
diesmal so richtig leise weil die sind
wirklich die ganze zeit da ruft ein
junge
okay leute hier sind wir wieder auf dem
server und ethik umgeht die runde wieder
los und hier ist mein partner he wants
die da ist auf jeden fall direkt
marketing
ich hab jetzt schon direkt was in kauf
für so viel cash alter fragt direkt fünf
minuten weg und nein aber es auf jeden
fall in ein neues investment direkt am
anfang
ich hoffe mal dass die schuss zeitgleich
zu ende ist es muss hier von jemand
ausgelöst werden jemand muss dieses item
auslöser detail keeper mit ich bin so
ein holzkopf weiter ich habe mich jede
rüstung für fünf minuten gekauft auch
schon wieder ist ein typ in der direkt
neben mir kommen auch man gebe ich offen
sagte larry ja locker el clasico spüren
dann ja der k
ich bin aus 2 gründen was ich bin aus
texten jeder muss einer sterben da muss
einer liefen keine chance gäste und
wieso wenn ich direkt enthüllte ja aber
du hast doch noch geht hier gar nichts
los
auch die zeit läuft gar nicht mehr ja
aber sterben normalerweise direkt leute
oder 54
ok ok hab ein hat ein alter schwede wie
es kann man das ding spielen kann
aber du kriegst du nur 30 sekunden oder
sonne habe noch ein habe noch ein jahr
kämpfte um sein leben gerungen
fakt ist es waren die wir noch zwei
minuten wieder oh mein gott alter
ich bin was soll die kacke mann
ich habe zwei steine kopf 40 sekunden
zeit immer neue junge rein werde sein
neues leben
ich habe mich keine ahnung was die karte
sollte wie ver klickt oder so ok der typ
hat anscheinend auch kein schwert ich
noch ein gestalter die runde geht mega
overkill bitte leute ich muss müssen
einfach überleben
ich habe auch nur 117 30 grad das ist
einiges für mich muss ich drei minuten o
mein gott ist das spannend 136 ich leide
und ich brauchte in der mitte gibt es
übrigens zeit wachsen
bei diesem einen turm also kannst du
aufladen daraufhin rückwärts gestorben
jähnigen tränke und food junge wiener
budget und heming und jazz plate alter
schwede lucky as [ __ ] is back also
zeitspeicher den kann zu kaufen und dann
kriegst du entweder zehn prozent weniger
oder bis 90 prozent mehr der
investierten zeit raus oder die übrigen
nicht mehr sprinten auf steht ja wo bist
du ich sollte foto open ist laut team
aber 66
ja ich kann die ersten tropfen ich kann
als gewöhnlich nach dem reißen essen
sender hat richtig viel aber es gibt
junge ich weiß was ich mache sondern hat
einen stern grad so viele ja ich bin
auch ehrlich gesagt relativ passiv
gerade wo alle hat die alle hds ich mich
nicht kommen niemals aktive hinweg
hinweg weite und zack zack 3 und wii
macht diese darüber lustig dass alle
leute hat eben alles wirklich eine alle
hd ich habe eine glocke in der hand was
kann ich da mitmachen wenn damit heute
schlägt klaus den zeit gut und leben
braucht expert.de mich hätten junge ist
es spannend ich habe also dafür dass ich
am anfang so riskant gespielt habe ist
mein job und das viele geld habe ist
meine stadt mein zeuge ich nicht so gut
finde ich
noch 255 s bahn erwarte ich muss weiter
ok ich sehe euch ja wahnsinn 2 kay ist
ist den bayern bossen not ihn sagte
stone
nein die wand wird von boy geschäfts
wäre als kammerjäger du wirst geschätzt
aber not ihm auch kaum schon mann der
antizipiert auch echt alles was ich
mache wenn ich feuer platzieren bildern
geht er auf die harfst labs wenn ich
trank geben wir dann läuft er weg
fucking brauchst bei der export als
lektor jetzt lecter alex nein ich hole
ihn wissen wer es war mein länger heute
love love love love love love
ich mache den fluss macht die flotte
hirsch wertvoll ist weder der hat ein
scheiß presse das war kein hit beim
reden aleikum her komm mal her was von
müssen wir betteln jetzt eigentlich wird
ist nichts für mich außer beim bruder
lassen müssen wir meinen stil fragen
wir müssen auf jeden fall nachher bei
den spätestens finale wahrscheinlichkeit
meint aber wieder feuer haben
36 wie viel hast du noch okay da und ist
aber auch einer 22
ich habe mir den ball komm runter
junge leute kennen die weniger zeit
lassen
ich bin merke ich bin egoistisch atego
ist kein realist ich bin so realistisch
lasst uns jetzt fein oder bevor wir die
zeit verdient ihre debatte mgm 250 hd
ist immer noch da ich sag dir ich
rausfliegen wege im nvidia agency cia
oder dann ist sie da machst du alleine
gm für den fall dass das so ist liegt
mein körper das bauen
ich habe richtig angst dass wir das der
nicht nur mgm seien auch energie also
milchschnitten mörder genk ist in der
gruppe oder maybelline jade maybelline
jade mit gel oder einfach weiter ich
habe nur einige zwölf ja- oder käufer
ansporn ich kann auch erkennen ja ich
bin noch da das muss einfach weiter du
kannst dein vater falten wie man kein
schaden
du kannst das in der mitte ich habe zwar
gesagt aber jetzt anderer wenigsten gm
gmc den goldabbau rein aber ich war ja
clip wie einst der eine ziemlich kaputt
gehen hat der liga entspannter konnte
jungen diese fälle vor die allesamt play
bin ich habe keinen guten bringen
da nicht so gemein zu mir okay alles
gleich hp emc verdauen kommen die miete
nicht raus du weißt du weißt du wie viel
für mich ist sein motto
übrigens sollte dieses mal schillers mag
nein ich wollte nur kurz sagen dass
dieses es ist nichts für mich einfach
ein job ist vereinfacht als versprochen
okay weil die neuen lasst uns kämpfen
einfach komfortabel nur gewinnen willst
kannst konform
ich hab' ich habe also ohne spaß meine
ich hab so krasses raindrops wenn ich
mich schnell drehen kündigte rainer sie
einfach der grafikkarte angstmache vor
wasserwerfern shopping gekommen das sind
meine taktik - china light oder ich lag
in beiden fällen aber wenn ihr server
ich kann noch gar nicht aber in zeiten
auf ja ja und diese täglich kaufen ist
es jetzt ich hab eine neue grafikkarte
diese lex aber das meer etwas merke dass
ich gemacht das ist dasselbe problem wie
aufkommen in der ende des rennens
das ist dann lässt das so richtig könig
wird teilweise ist es komisch also
ehrlich ich weiß nicht wenn ihr das
kennt das problem oder so schreibt
kommentare vielleicht nicht mehr an eine
neue grafikkarte kaufen weil ich hab
jetzt schon also ptx 760 ist oder war
ist auf jeden fall spannend gewesen wie
noch was mit den acht sekunden wieder
alle die ich direkt zum starten hatte
und hat spaß gemacht oder und beim
nächsten mal besser